i know everybody kept coming up to you
being like you ready for the scene
you're like we're like i don't know am i
ready for it
[Music]
i think it starts with the script for me
and then you hope the creative team
around it lives up to the level of
writing that you were drawn into variety
is is a big thing for me i would say
especially
after six years of one thing that i
loved being able to show different
colors is always something really
exciting i gotta say it's different
reasons sometimes it's the director it's
your co-stars the script
obviously always something that's a
little bit scary that you're like i
wonder can i do it or something where
i'm like i just don't stop thinking
about it and it may not be that it's
like incredible but it's like why can't
i stop thinking about that script it's
an intangible hook good word good words
guys
[Music]
you know dhamma has so many beat changes
and you know you read something and
you're like oh wait it's a lot of beat
changes in the scene but in a sentence
in like three sentences you're shifting
gears a lot yeah there are days when
like your focus you know becomes a
little bit higher but like and i don't
think i have to articulate it like when
you're around a good crew folks just
sort of naturally give you space yeah
they can feel it and then i can and then
they feel it when it sort of like eases
up again and they come up and talk to
you and they're like oh man that was
really cool well i think the great thing
about this is adama always gave us
something we didn't know we needed you
know it's like we'd come with how like
oh this is how we've interpreted it it's
great and then there'd just be one way
she turned it left or right or a little
on its head and so that was fun you know
but what i think what we had to have
more than anything was memorization to
be able to play and make those kinds of
adjustments it was definitely not a
oh i'll wing it right no you can't be
searching for stuff because she would
give you such differing sort of things
that that were in your head that like
you have to have some sort of facility
with words in order to play yeah as
seamlessly as possible yeah
[Music]